hey guys it is the 21st of January today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching gamespot news Windows 10 seems
to be pleasing people so far but here's
a few more awesome things we found out
about today at Microsoft Windows 10
events first up Microsoft have announced
a wearable device called the microsoft
hololens designed to work with their new
augmented reality platform windows
holographic the hollow lens create
see-through HD holographics and the unit
includes spatial sound and sensors that
capture environment information it has
three onboard processes a GPU cpu and a
holographic processing unit which will
understand where you're looking your
gestures your voice and is capable of
spatially nothing your environment
Microsoft have said this wireless and
standalone augmented reality device
isn't intended to compete with virtual
reality and wearable offerings like
oculus rift and opal glass but instead
have invited them to work on the
platform if you still prefer console
gaming you'll be pleased to know that
Windows 10 is going to support Xbox one
game streaming later this year in the
same way that steam in-home streaming or
PlayStation TV and Vita streaming works
you can even stream to Windows tablets
if you happen to be a cashed-up
individual who got your hands on a
surface pro finally Microsoft are giving
out windows 10 as a free upgrade if you
already have Windows 8.1 windows phone
8.1 or Windows 7 if you like me never
took the terrifying windows 8 plunge the
offer is available for the first 12
months after windows 10 launches today
we find ourselves asking who hacks the
hackers well it turns out somebody did
and justice has been served as the
infamous lizard squad who took down PSN
and xbox live over the Christmas break
I've got what's coming to them the
lizard squads hacking operation which
lets customers nominate a website that
the group will take down for a small fee
as itself been packed which is awesome
all 14,000 241 people
signed up to the service have had their
details obtained and an 18 year old
English man who's arrested in
conjunction with the deed after tax last
Christmas he was also arrested on
suspicion of being involved in swatting
which is that really scumbag move of
tricking emergency services into
thinking someone is being unlawful to
the extent that their house gets raided
ultimately terrifying the victims and
wasting everybody's time and emu that
shouldn't surprise anybody the paid
subscription MMO is pretty much dead
unless you're Wow since today the Elder
Scrolls online has thrown its mandatory
subscription fee out the window after
taking their game off shelves all over
the place Bethesda have said they're
going to dissolve the mandatory paid
subscription the news came at the same
time is the june nine release date for
the ps4 and xbox one versions of the
game was announced the subscription free
version of the game is now called the
elder scrolls online Tamriel unlimited
and includes all the content from the
current game plus all updates and
content additions the pc version will go
live on much 17 and if you've already
got it you won't have to buy it again if
you do want to keep paying your
subscription for some reason you'll be
getting elder scrolls online plus which
comes with exclusive in-game bonuses a
monthly allotment of premium game money
and access to all DLC packs let me know
if you'd play the other Scrolls online
now that it's free and what you think of
all the windows 10 announcements you can
add the game spot for more news on
things like criticism of Nintendo's
business plan and Microsoft's still
trying to make Internet Explorer happen
those it from me and it's very long use
episode today thanks for hanging around
and I will catch you same time tomorrow
you